[Música]
[Aplausos]
1989 el año que cambió el mundo o así lo
expresa un historiador catedrático de
historia contemporánea por la
universidad de valladolid ricardo martín
de la guardia en su libro sobre los
orígenes del orden internacional después
de la guerra fría él define 1989 como
uno de esos años claves en la historia y
son años claves porque suponen una
aceleración de los acontecimientos y a
la vez una recogida de acontecimientos
acaecidos en décadas pasadas son años
trampolín
pues bien 1989 fue un año muy importante
para mí personalmente un año de estos
trampolín en mi futuro profesional y
personal y a la vez la recogida de lo
acaecido en años anteriores yo recién
había acabado mis estudios de turismo y
hostelería y tras algunos trabajitos de
estos de verano
como guía para grupos del imserso
limpiando habitaciones en hoteles de
recepcionista en un camping en 1989 tuve
mi primer trabajo formal
veo sus caras hay alguien en el público
que no había nacido en 1989
por favor que levanten la mano madre mía
ahora entiendo esas caras ya bajar las
manos y gracias por insultar nos con
vuestra juventud muchas gracias
en 1989 yo tuve mi primer trabajo formal
me contrato una cadena hotelera un grupo
local un negocio familiar que gestionaba
y gestiona un hotel en barcelona y
cuatro hoteles en tossa de mar en la
costa brava y realmente fue un trabajo
fantástico y yo empecé de telefonista en
el hotel de barcelona y enseguida me
ofrecieron irme a la costa brava los
hoteles que gestionaban en verano tuve
un trabajo en el que yo era secretaria
de gerente y en realidad los títulos
nunca me han importado me han importado
las responsabilidades fue de esos
trabajos donde aprendes de todo hacía
realmente de secretaría de mi jefe hacía
las cajas de los restaurantes de los
bares me metían la operativa tenía pues
conversaciones con los bancos con los
proveedores con las agencias de viaje de
esos trabajos donde desarrollas tu
aprendizaje y lo más importante y por
eso lo traigo con ustedes hoy es que
aquel fue el primer trabajo donde yo
tuve uno de esos jefes líderes que de
verdad aportan valor a tu talento
porque esto va de talento y aquí hemos
escuchado a los compañeros hoy es decir
diferentes aportaciones sobre el talento
yo creo que a estas alturas ya nos hemos
dado cuenta de que el talento lo
descubrimos de dos maneras una por
auto-conocimiento y la otra gracias a la
visión de otros y yo tengo la suerte de
que he tenido gente a lo largo de mi
carrera que me ha ayudado a ver lo bueno
que hay en mí y yo creo que este talento
también lo he desarrollado de cara a
otros el yo ayudar a otros en el
desarrollo de su talento
creo que soy lo que soy gracias a la
ayuda de otros y lo que quiero
aprovechar hoy con todos ustedes son
cuatro ideas porque este es nuestro
bloque de ideas que he aprendido a lo
largo del camino y que me han ayudado a
conocerme mejor primero y segundo me han
ayudado mucho a desarrollar el talento
de otros
la primera
me la dio un jefe cuando yo trabajaba en
la cadena hotelera internacional en
cancún un gran jefe de estos líderes que
tienen se llamaba enrique y él me dijo
en una ocasión
olga tienes un don y ese don es que
sabes rodearte de gente que es mejor que
tú
yo tenía 25 años cuando me dijo este
reconocimiento y hoy por hoy pues ya
calculan que más que dobló esa edad y de
verdad miro hacia atrás y pienso de
verdad que esa ha sido la clave de mi
éxito pero hay algo que aprendí de él
hay algo que me enseñó enrique está muy
bien rodéate de gente que sea mejor que
tú pero no sólo el talento aporta
rodéate de gente que te aporte
diversidad
gente que sea diferente a ti y otra de
las cosas que ha aprendido jamás desde
la dirección de recursos humanos es que
muchas veces cuando hacemos selección
tendemos a querer rodearnos de gente que
sea como nosotros de gente que piensa
como nosotros que vea el negocio como
nosotros que sí soy extrovertida pues
quiero ser vertidos en mis equipos y eso
es un gran error hay que rodearse de
gente que aporte diversidad de los
equipos y gente buena muy buena no tenga
miedo siempre vamos a estar por encima
en cuestiones de liderazgo y otra de las
cosas que ha aprendido y de hecho me la
habéis reforzado todos los compañeros
que habéis hablado antes que yo es que
la actitud es importante cuando hablamos
de gente buena no es sólo gente buena
técnicamente sino gente con la mejor
actitud como dice alguien que seguro que
han visto en alguna charla ted víctor
coopers
te suena tenía una foto pero bueno
míreme a mí
víctor dice que las personas somos como
bombillas hay gente que a 3.000 vatios
por la vida y hay gente que va fundida y
otro grande que he seguido también
entonces álvaro gonzález alorda
y él dice hay dos tipos de personas las
que te ponen gasolina y las que te la
quitan por lo tanto eso es lo que
aprendí he intentado inculcar lo a los
demás rodé monos de gente buena de gente
que aporte valor talento y con la mejor
actitud y lo que más ilusión me hace es
que ya no solo ustedes sino las personas
que van a oír mi charla y que han
trabajado conmigo a lo largo de todos
estos años pues bueno que se queden con
esto que fueron buenos muy buenos si no
no hubieran estado en mis equipos
el segundo aprendizaje que quiero
compartir con ustedes hoy los trajes de
un gran jefe que tuve también en un
hotel en barcelona en hotel de lujo
donde yo era jefe de recepción y él me
dio mucho reconocimiento por mi
entusiasmo es que ya ven que lo mantengo
eres muy entusiasta olga tienes mucha
iniciativa tienes mucha motivación que
conduces a la gente hacia resultados y
sin embargo con él aprendí algo muy
importante y es que todas las monedas
tienen dos caras
y a veces una cualidad en exceso puede
convertirse en un defecto con el
aprendiz que ser entusiasta está muy
bien pero que a veces hay que regular el
entusiasmo para no bloquear a otros o
con el aprendiz que tener iniciativa
está muy bien pero a veces hay que saber
dar un paso atrás para dejar que otros
den un paso nantes aprendí a escuchar
aprendí a no querer tener siempre la
última palabra y le estoy muy agradecida
por eso así que gracias luis y voy a
seguir la misma técnica ya nada
el tercer aprendizaje que quiero
compartir con ustedes
me hizo verlo resolutiva que soy esto ya
fue cuando pase de operaciones a
recursos humanos trabajé con dos
directores de recursos humanos
fantásticos que me hicieron ver olga
eres resolutiva no le tienes miedo al
conflicto ante una situación adversa
tienes la necesidad de darle la vuelta y
sin embargo
tienes que aprender de los errores es
algo que hemos oído en las charlas
anteriores de la vida de ti marc se lo
hemos seguido a víctor aprende de los
errores tropezar está bien enamorarte de
la piedra no
eso es lo que aprendí con marta
comiencen mis directores de recursos
humanos y es algo que créanme sigue
siendo un poco mi talón de aquiles mi
marido aquí presente cierto es tiendo a
seguir enamorando me de las piedras y
darle muchas vueltas a las cosas y
siempre tengo este aprendizaje en mente
está bien avancemos piedra fuera del
camino con eso ya no me tropezar eh que
me tropecé con otra diferente
el cuarto aprendizaje que quiero
compartir con todos ustedes es algo que
hoy muy recientemente de hecho lo
escuché hace una semana en la ceremonia
de clausura del año académico de la
escuela de negocios donde trabajo en
barcelona y sólo escuché a un compañero
a un profesor director de programas en
su curso de clausura hacia los alumnos y
dijo algo que para mí está muy
relacionado con la esencia del network
de las redes profesionales que es la
generosidad porque al fin y al cabo el
network es un acto de generosidad que
puedo hacer yo por ti que puedes hacer
tú por mí y lo que él dijo en el
discurso fue lo siguiente se hace está
amables con la gente que os encontráis
cuando las cosas van bien porque os los
vais a encontrar de nuevo cuando las
cosas van mal
creo que este aprendizaje es como muy
común y realmente me he dado cuenta de
que en ocasiones en la industria
hotelera somos muy piña somos que todo
es un colectivo que incluso gente que
hace años que no nos vemos nos
mantenemos muy en contacto y cada vez
que nos hemos enterado que alguien
necesitaba algo que alguien se había
quedado sin trabajo
todos nos volcamos hacia esa persona y a
mí también me ha ocurrido han habido
momentos de transición creanme de crisis
de búsqueda laboral y la gente se ha
volcado a ayudarme y sin embargo en
algunas ocasiones tengo que decir que
pocas ha ocurrido que gente acude a ti
porque se ha quedado sin trabajo y
piensas bueno veré lo que puedo hacer
pero en el fondo no tienes una gran
motivación por ayudar a esa persona
les ha ocurrido alguna vez
si no les ha ocurrido les va a ocurrir y
entonces piensen en esto quizás si no
tenemos ganas de ayudar a esa persona de
corazón es porque esa persona no ha sido
suficientemente generosa o
suficientemente profesional cuando todas
las cosas iban bien ese es otro gran
aprendizaje que quiero compartir con
ustedes
y porque esto va de talento
voy a finalizar mi charla con una
llamada a la acción y con el final de
una historia
la llamada a la acción
se basa en lo que estamos creando aquí
en esta comunidad en esta charla te de
c's lo que estamos haciendo es un
diálogo abierto un diálogo común y lo
que me gustaría es pues fomentar más
esta inspiración para la acción por lo
tanto vamos a tener deberes cosas que
podemos hacer tomar responsabilidad y de
hecho es algo que se ha reforzado
también durante las charlas el talento
es una responsabilidad desde dos puntos
de vista desde el autoconocimiento y
aquí les dejo con las generosas palabras
de valentín fuster cardiólogo y él dice
dedicarse tiempo a conocerse a uno mismo
y apostar por nuestro talento es una de
las mejores inversiones que podemos
hacer lo ha mencionado césar también en
la charla a veces las cosas que no hacen
en el colegio pues las tenemos que hacer
nosotros mismos y sobre todo aquellas
personas que han levantado la mano
porque no habían nacido en 1989 más
todavía tienen que a veces estamos en
estos momentos de transición profesional
donde la gente no se inculca y mucho que
vas a estudiar que vas a trabajar que
vas a hacer y como tú dices es como esa
decisión que la tienes que tomar en un
momento de codazo y esto no va de esto
esto no va de trabajo los trabajos van y
vienen esto va de talento y de
desarrollar aquellas cosas que de verdad
se nos da bien
y lo segundo es esta responsabilidad
también de cara a otros y ahí también
les voy a dejar deberes y deberes
inspirados en las palabras de álvaro
gonzález alorda el que antes mencioné
que dice en sus charlas ted hay dos
tipos de personas las que te ponen
gasolina y las que te la quitan también
dice la calidad del liderazgo está en la
calidad de nuestras conversaciones
por lo tanto tómense el tiempo el lunes
cuando vuelvan a sus trabajos a sus
equipos a sus proyectos de decirle a las
personas que están en sus equipos qué es
lo que realmente hacen bien cuáles son
sus habilidades del reconocimiento en
esos talentos que están ahí si es que no
lo han hecho antes por favor
porque también les digo una cosa si el
lunes cuando vayan a sus trabajos a sus
proyectos miran a alguien de sus equipos
y piensan que este no tiene ningún
talento de ninguna habilidad entonces yo
les pregunto y que hacen tu equipo
qué está haciendo ahí
por lo tanto tómense el tiempo también
de darnos feedback el talento muchos lo
hemos descubierto gracias a la ayuda de
otros
para finalizar el final de mi historia
esta charla empezó en 1989 de hecho
empezó hace casi 13 minutos pero bueno
1989 quiero compartir con ustedes otro
año que creo que va a ser clave en mi
vida y es este 2019 y si hacemos
cálculos rápidos cuanto ha pasado
treinta años treinta años redondos bueno
pues se acuerdan que les dije que en
1989 tuve mi primer trabajo formal y me
contrato ese primer jefe que conoces en
tu vida jefe líder pues la semana pasada
pasó algo fantástico y es que me volví a
reencontrar con esa persona 30 años
después
fue un encuentro organizado por su hija
a la que contacté a través de redes
profesionales su hija una mujer de 32
años que actualmente gestiona los
hoteles y a la que yo conocí cuando era
un bebé y yo trabajaba con esa familia
la contacté por linkedin le dije yo
trabajé con tu padre en 1989 anda y
pregúntale porque no tiene perfil anda y
pregunta gente si se acuerda de mí y me
contestó vaya si se acuerda y
organizamos un encuentro sorpresa y fue
maravilloso fue maravilloso primero
porque nos reconocimos y nos mentimos
eso estás igual no estás mejor bueno en
fin y fue maravilloso porque tuve la
oportunidad de decirle que había sido un
jefe muy importante para mí y me alegré
de poder decírselo ahora porque entonces
no lo sabía yo entonces era muy joven y
no tenía otros ejemplos con que comparar
por lo tanto el poder decirle louis
porque se llama louis fuiste un jefe
importante para mí y por qué porque
fuiste un jefe
profesional porque gestionando un
negocio familiar nos hiciste ver lo
profesional del negocio cosa que no he
visto en otras situaciones porque nos
decías en por qué de todo lo que
hacíamos y contigo el aprendizaje era
diario y él me dio feedback a mí y me
dijo olga tú también dejaste huella y
dejaste huella por tu entusiasmo por tus
ganas de aprender por tu carácter
resolutivo
sorpresa las cosas que he ido oyendo
sobre mí a lo largo del camino también
he titulado mi charla la huella del
talento y con este mensaje les quiero
dejar yo quiero que de verdad reforzamos
la idea de que algunos invierten mucho
el autoconocimiento otros invertimos
mucho en escuchar lo que los demás
piensan de nosotros y somos lo que somos
gracias a la ayuda de otros y yo quiero
que esta charla y que este espacio que
tengo la suerte de poder compartir con
ustedes sea un homenaje para todas
aquellas personas que han trabajado
conmigo y que me han ayudado a ver mi
talento y también hay algo que he
descubierto de mí misma y es que lo que
es de verdad de verdad de verdad se me
ha dado bien es desarrollar el talento
de los demás y ahora con el transcurso
de los años que muchos seguimos en
contacto y a otros les sigo por redes y
veo dónde están y lo que hacen pues me
siento orgullosa me siento orgullosa de
donde han llegado a nivel personal y
profesional y me siento orgullosa de
haber puesto mi granito de arena en esta
evolución
esto es la huella del talento porque
dejar huella es tener impacto en los
demás y dejar huella es dejar a las
cosas e incluso a las personas mejor de
lo que las encontramos muchas gracias
y